would you build a house without a
blueprint I hope not a business model is
like a blueprint for planning building
and evolving your business in this
course we will learn what makes the most
successful business models work and how
to apply those lessons to design or
reinvent your own business models I am
Professor high menderson from the
Stanford Graduate School of Business and
I've been teaching for years how to
benefit from the framework that you will
learn in this course whether you are an
executive with an Innovative idea to
transform your organization or an
entrepreneur building your business from
the ground up this course is for you our
business model architecture framework
will give you a proven tool for turning
your vision into a reality we analyze
companies such as Tesla Amazon modern
and apple and here from senior
Executives at Google and Airbnb other
companies have reimagined their business
models to meet changing customer needs
it is a bet that we're taking between
the short term and the long term how do
we create a truly magical experience and
we shoot for that so what is the more
General lesson from this open doors for
some of these conversations with
Partners it was a difficult task to get
everyone to buy into this concept that
didn't yet exist but that we said would
really create a better future
digital Technologies accompanied by
changes in demographics customer needs
and supply chain structures are
disrupting and transforming every
industry in every part of the world so
no matter who you are or what company
you work for sooner or later you're
going to need a new business model I
look forward to seeing you in class at
Stanford online
[Music]